hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 1918 tournament in New York
it's josé raúl capablanca versus Serbian
Grandmaster Borislav Kostich and even
though the the official title of
Grandmaster did not exist in those days
boys of course which was one of the
first people ever to receive the title
of Grand Master in 1950 so but I I mean
I I do call them grandmasters it would
be silly enough to call capablanca and
and the other guys here grandmasters so
that being said it's really an intense
game it's a still a double round-robin I
mean it's the same tournament and we
skipped a couple uncas game against
Baraka stitch in the first part of the
tournament I was a pretty much a
textbook draw so I decided not to cover
it pretty much like two modern-day
grandmasters played out an engine light
all the way to a draw so not much to
show there but this game is entirely
different a lot going on here so I
really do do hope you enjoy it so we can
nicely finish up this 1918 tournament of
New York that being said Capablanca has
the white pieces and he opens with efore
with f5 and Knight to f3 and we have
Knight to f6 Kostich goes for the petrol
defense and if you remember some time
ago during the couple Blanco saga we
mentioned that one of the few lines
Capablanca actually did study is how to
play against the petrov
so tonight chapters on e5 a nice modern
day replied the six Knight back to f3
non Knight captures an e4 and d4 this is
still to this day the main line with d5
and now Bishop to d3 attacking the
knight Bishop to e7 Capablanca castles
and knights to c6
we have c4 here and here Knight
back to f6 also possible today is nice
to be four but here we have Knight to f6
by Kostich C captors on d5 Knight
captures on d5 and now Knight to c3 and
it's still aligned that's very very much
popular in modern chess for example in
2014 in Croatian championship in Portage
even charge had this position against
anti-shah reach and ant
continuing with Bishop three six and
even one a very nice game there but here
we have castles by Kostich and now come
rook to e1 and here Bishop to e6 and
again still online that was played a lot
of times in modern chess
for example Boris Gelfand was a big fan
of this line with the black pieces
Alexander Greek had it against Boris
Gelfand in 2006 agree she lost that game
after continuing with a3 a3 is a is an
improvement
to this position because in those days
you didn't have ancients so of course I
move like a3 was most likely considered
a waste of time also an opponent she had
it in 2011 against also Boris Gelfand
that game ended in a draw but a3 is well
the engines improvement today but then
in 1918 capablanca just played nicely
for a nice human move he's a grabbing
hold of the the g5 square also avoiding
any unnecessary trades he wants to keep
as many pieces on the board and he
already want the tournament so he
doesn't really have to worry about that
he just wants to play a nice game and
you know just enjoy is some good chess
with Knight back to f6 by Kostich in now
Knight f to g5 just putting a lot of
pressure on this h7 pawn if the Knights
are traded here then even the Queen can
infiltrate with Queen to h5 and of
course hostage is not interested in
giving up the light square bishop so
Bishop to f5 with Knight captures and f6
with check with Bishop captures and now
Bishop captures an f5 bushel captures
and g5 and here Capablanca plays d5 and
okay it's a very nice move but you know
you always have to check if a move like
Bishop captures h7 works you know just
in case here it almost works but it
doesn't if Bishop captures of course can
characters and now Queen to h5 check you
will block with the bishop and now after
Bishop captures here G captures Queen f5
check you can go King g8 and now rook
III and of course it all makes sense you
want to go rogue g3 you know finish up
at the attack but black can simply
defend Queen captures on d4
and now after rubies to recheck King h8
you don't have a good follow up if rook
h3 if you go after the pawn queen d6
just defense and
Queen g5 hoping to win the Queen here
King h7 defense and now you don't really
have any more useful ideas Queen a5 will
be met with Queen g6 black defended and
you don't have good compensation for
your sacrificed piece so although it
doesn't work you know you should always
check if maybe it works
so here d5 the Knight has to be moved
from there with nice the befall you can
go to e 7 because you the Queen has to
keep an eye on the bishop on g5 so nice
to be 4 and now comes looked efore a
very nice look lifted by capablanca
comes into the game with an attack on
the night so a5 defending and now Queen
to h5 capablanca is really starting a
beautiful attack here we have h6 just
defending and now rook to g4 couple
Blanca like I said he already won the
tournament he wants to play just play a
beautiful chess here so Bishop captures
on c1 with rook captures on c1 and now
again you have to be you have to be
careful with black here if you try
something like g6 you you could easily
blunder the game away after white
sacrifices Brooke you know checkmate it
will very soon follow
so here looked a 6 the rook now controls
the g6 square also the h6 pawn so you
cannot capture Queen captures on h6 was
also a threat so Bishop to e4 now maybe
also with ideas of Queen f5 followed by
Queen to h7 checkmate
so here hostage finds a very interesting
line f5 now forcing White's the capture
on f5 with Bishop captures on f5 and now
comes Queen captures on d5 grabbing that
pawn also the bishop now cannot move as
then the Queen trade can occur and I
mean it's a again a very interesting
line here cap of Lanka has to make a
choice does he want to go for the safe
Bishop g6 which offers a queen trade
where black if black trade trades Queens
it's gonna be pretty much a draw in game
but the problem is black has Queen to d2
it's a very annoying move and after rook
to f1 as you do have to defend both the
rook and the f2 pawn so rook to ff1 and
now rook comes to f6 and all of a sudden
it's black who's on the attack and here
it would just be something like roof
Bishop three four and now okay you can't
capture it would be very unfortunate if
you did if you play something like rook
captures here then you get rook captures
and g7 you again run into checkmate but
you would most likely meet this position
with Queen captures and B to just
continue playing the game and it would
be somewhat better position for black
white doesn't really have a good way of
continuing the attack here so after this
Queen d5 move capablanca finds a very
interesting line rook captures on g7 and
okay for a moment you don't have the
same option of delivering checkmate
because we already said that the row
covers the g6 worse so this maneuver is
out of the question we have Queen King
captures and g7 and now Queen to g4
check a very important check that well
positions the Queen where the Queen
needs the B and also still keeps an eye
on the d1 square so the rook can capture
and c7 without you having to worry about
any checkmating ideas on d1 we have King
the8 and now rook captures in c7 again
capablanca threatens checkmate on g7
while guarding the d1 square not
allowing black to deliver checkmate
so again hostage has to be very careful
here if you go something like Ruby g8
you get her rook h7 checkmate not
something you want to allow so he goes
to Queen to g8 but now this this is what
Capablanca had in mind with rook to h7
and giving up a look for the Queen and
the bishop Queen captures Bishop
captures King captures and now Queen to
d7 check
so what's couple Blancas compensation
for so much material Black has two rooks
and night and three points against the
Queen and five points so it's black is
actually off material here but with cost
King being so loose and Capablanca can
just deliver as many checks as he wants
he wants the grab as much material as
possible here with King to g8 and now a3
forcing the Knights to move and here
it's a very delicate position here if
cost which goes something you can't go
something like Knights to a two if you
go an eye to a two then 25 will simply
pick up the night if you go something
like nice to see six or night to see two
again you will get Queen captures and b7
with an attack on the rook and after the
rook
now you will get Quinn to d5 and again
it's a very very interesting position
you pin the rook rook f6 defending an
out h4 making some room for your king
and the knight doesn't really have all
that many options of entering the game
you can go 91 but then h5 and after what
black plays something a 40 you will pick
up that pawn with check Queen captures
and you will now have this position
where black Black Knight isn't very
comfortable there and you will have two
connected passed pawns that you will
start pushing and I mean it's a it's
very hard to say if white can actually
win this but at least with with the
black King being so loose capablanca can
draw this to Eternity and then maybe
maybe win someday but Casta doesn't like
this line he prefers a different one he
goes who rook the c6 first threatens
checkmate after rook c1 you block with
the Queen and and of course it's
checkmate and couple unka has to react
to this first h4 just making some
breathing room for the king and now
Knight goes to a 6 of course you have to
give up the pawns there's no way of
saving all material we have Queen
captures on b7 look after f6 now putting
more defense on the 6th rank and now
Queen to b5 going after the a 5 point we
have looked the c5 costly she doesn't
allow it the rook now from f6 defends
the night and the row from c5 defends
the point so he's trying to keep
everything intact Queen e8 check we have
king to g7 and now Queen to e7 check
rook to f7 and now Queen to b6 again
attacking the knight with ideas of going
h5 and even Queen to g6
so first rook the c1 by Kostich this
comes with check King to h2 and now
comes Knight to c5 we have h5 by
capablanca threatening Queen to g6 check
and now rook to have sex pushing the
Queen back Queen c7 check rook to f7 and
now Queen to g3 check with King to f8
and now Queen to d6 check and now you no
longer have the option of retreating the
g7 because now Queen g6 will just be
deadly you will go King f8 Queen
captures and h6 with check and you pick
up the rook on c1 so a huge problem for
black so after
quinta d6 check we have King to g8 and
not allowing the Queen to grab the h6
pawn with check but Capablanca still
grabs it with Queen captures on h6 and
now rook the c4 getting the rock out of
harm's way
Queen g5 check clearing the way for the
H bond with King to f/8 and now comes b3
checking what hostage will do with the
rook as the rook has to keep an eye on
the knight on c5 we have looked the c2
and now finally capablanca finds a very
nice tactic Queen b8 check with King to
g7 and now Queen to d4 check King to h7
and now b4 and now you see the problem
with a capture stand before a capture
some before and you cannot move the
knight because the knight controls the D
3 and E 4 squares either of these
maneuvers with the Queen will deliver
check and pick up the rock and c2 if you
move the knight so it's not an option
we have rook F captures and f2 now of
course that she decides to give up the
night but at least he's gonna have some
perpetual checking ideas here with B
captures on c5 rook captures and g2 with
check with rubus or King to h3 and now
again Costas has to decide how to go
about this
now I mean it's 2 rooks against the
queen but the the past pawns are very
strong and fast for example if you try
some checks here I mean it's very easy
to run away King you four you can go
Rosie to checking or three if you try
this then
I mean it's simple doesn't work so white
can just give up the Queen back for two
rooks and then of course the past point
is winning so Costas tries a different
line rook G to D 2 pushes the Queen back
we have Queen to e4 check King to g7 and
here we have the crucial moment of the
game that pretty much decided the title
of the video that I use used so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the winning idea for kappa blanka
here and how to how to go about this
position in general you know just you
know decide what what would you play
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
you know Queen maneuver and for those
who just want to enjoy the show here
kappa blanka played cease
but c6 does not win ce6 allows black a
beautiful beautiful drawing line but
this is not what we're looking for
what couple blanca had to play was
Quinta f3 and now you really don't have
a good way of defending with black the
c5 point is off limits if you capture it
then you will always be able to grab at
least one of the rooks for example h6
now you cannot capture if King captures
then just Queen Queen f4 or III check
will pick up the rook this rook or this
room doesn't really matter
and if you go King g6 then comes Queen
efore check King to h5 if you still
don't want to grab the pawn and now
Queen to ei to check Queen King to g5 or
captures on h6 doesn't really matter and
now you finally get Queen e3 check and
now either of the rooks it will be just
you know perfectly fine and you will of
course win the game so this is what
couple Blanca had to play but you know
he didn't but even if Queen to f3 and
you start delivering some checks let's
say rook gauge to check King g3 you
still can't deliver any more checks as
well
white would always give up the Queen for
two rooks and if you try something like
King h6 then you get Quinta efore again
just keeping around the g2 squares so no
checks are possible and now after King
characters on h5 you would get c6 the
pawn starts marching up the board if
Ruki to who you would just go Queen f3
check King g6 and now after c7 Black has
no good way of defending against
queening as he constantly has to keep an
eye on one of the rooks if rook eb -
you're just gonna play c8 queen allow
black to capture it and then you will
pick up one of the one of the rooks
either way
rook we let's say queenie for checking
f7 Queen f4 check picks up the rook here
and now after you move it just captures
and that's that's game if you don't know
how to play with the Queen against the
rook it's it's a very important
principle you should learn it as you
know chances are you will you will have
this position on your board more more
often than not so after King to g7 a
couple Blanca did not play Queen to f3
Queen g6 allows a lot of checks between
two f3 is just just winning so here a
couple one complete c6 thinking that
okay
just play King g3 and the next move and
then of course any checks with the rook
will not be possible but here Kostich
found a beautiful drawing line I'll give
you a couple seconds to find that move
as well so you know do your best for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
defender with a pair of rooks and for
those of you who just want to enjoy this
the show looked the c3 check it's a very
nice idea because now capablanca played
link to g4 and now rook beat the c2 this
is the movie have to find now your than
just threatening to win that pawn and of
course your threatening look to c4 to
win the Queen so here if you try to run
away like taking a five you you're gonna
get through c5 check and now after King
to e6 you're just gonna lose this pawn
and it's just gonna be very unpleasant
you have to go King D 7 or E 7 if you go
back you can even lose the game just
rook here check followed by Roxy for
wins the Queen so very unpleasant for
capablanca to allow this but you know
even even he even the the great cup of
longer can make a mistake here he played
25 check with King to h7 and here Queen
to e7 check King to h6 now comes Queen
to f8 check King to h7 and here finally
Capablanca played h6 hoping to deliver
checkmate on the next move but here cos
you just play rook to g2 check and it
was in this position animal 56 that
Hotel Kappa Lanka and the borders of
postage agreed to a draw
why is it the draw because you can't
constantly have to go king each four
kings you for king h4 King before you of
course cannot go here as you're gonna
lose the Queen and then of course black
will win the game so there's no other
way to go about this then then by
repeating King moves so that's the game
and really a wonderful game by both
capablanca and Kostich for a couple unka
created some chances with some you know
they're very very exciting and
interesting play but then he missed his
chance here where he should have played
Queen f3
but Kostich found a brilliant defensive
line and he was able to draw game
against Capablanca and now as this was
the last game we will be showing in the
1918 tournament of new york
we are of course going to check out the
standings here are the standings sorry
not that but that's also very nice photo
here are the standings so as you can see
Capablanca won the tournament point and
half ahead of borislav cottage so he won
the tournament even before playing this
game against Kostich but still was a it
was a very nice game but as you can see
ten and a half out of 12 so 9 wins 0
losses and 3 drawers and borislav cost
in second place you can see the how
strong host which was 9 out of 12
so 6 wins also 0 losses and six draws so
as you can see cost which played a
tournament a double round-robin where he
faced capablanca twice and he did not
suffer a single loss and he even
finished 2 points ahead of Frank James
Marshall who is who was a you know a
brilliant player then Oscar highs with 6
out of 12
davia no ski 4 out of 12 Roy Turnbull
black the Honorable 3 and a half of 12
and John Stuart Morrison 2 out of 12
just just a very nice tournament and I'm
very happy that we went through it you
know in its entirety so yeah and I also
felt it was really important to check
out this game even though it ended in a
draw but it was a really an exciting
draw you know a lot of things could have
gone wrong for both copper and and Bora
but in the end I'm just very satisfied
with this game I hope you enjoyed it as
well and since the next thing you are
covering in a couple months ago is
Capablanca this match against Borislav
Kostich in Cuba Havana so I think this
was you know a pretty nice pre lute to
this to this very nice match which is
also a pre root 2 couple uncas match
with emmanuel a scorer for the World
Chess Championship title but yeah we're
gonna you know continue doing that as
you know so you know as much as I can
during you know any other tournament
that goes on sure that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Robin via when Kristensen Jeff
graves Anthony Cox and Nathaniel Pomeroy
for a conclusion to my channel thank you
a lot - really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I
soon hopefully with more interesting
content continuing the Capablanca saga
and of course checking up and on your
suggestions and what's interesting in
the world of chess I think you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday